ce ratio est celle d'une nouvelle façon
d'afficher vos notifications c'est
vachement bien je vous montre vous allez
ici dans vos réglages et vous allez sur
vos notifications alors vous pouvez soit
avoir des notifications en nombre à vous
mais juste que le nombre de
notifications vous avez soit ample il la
voulait les unes sur les autres et
lorsque vous appuyez ça voulait déroule
ou alors vous mettez une liste la liste
en plus de place pour pas sa terrible ce
que je vous recommande de faire c'est de
me remettre la pile comme ça vous voyez
les notifications elles sont regroupées
vous appuyez salé ou salés déroule et ça
c'est vachement bien